the true sign of madness if you do the  same thing over and over again and  expect a different result we can't go  back go back go back to the very same  policies that failed us in the last  decade go back to failed policies  dramatic government action Bush backed  bailouts Obama back bailouts Bush signed  a stimulus package Obama signed a  stimulus package I childish I'd some of  my free market principles Bush passed a  giant health care entitlement Obama did  to push past the giant financial  regulation bill Obama did to Bush spent  like mad Obama did to the numbers are  staggering and from gigantic deficits to  the drug war two pork politics you won't  find much change to believe in can't go  back to the very same policies that  failed us in the last decade go back to  failed policies feels like we never left